der vater seinem sohn so und ich muss
dir was sagen so wurde es adoptiert sagt
der sohn was ich würde keine echten
eltern kennen dann darauf der vater wir
sind keine echten eltern und jetzt mach
dich fertig du wirst in 20 minuten
abgeholt verstehst du denn
hallo
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
feiern wir ein video ja da ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut wir sind hier
heute mal im wald das ist hier so meinen
standard wald ich mache ja auch ab und
zu noch sport wieso zweimal die woche
hier sorgen also ich kenne mich hier aus
wie in meiner westentasche und wir haben
uns gedacht machen wir doch mal ein
bisschen sport zusammen wir machen heute
was wirklich cool ist und zwar kam felix
auf die idee lass uns doch einfach mal
ne liegestütz challenge machen
das heißt wir machen jetzt gleich
liegestütz aber nicht ganz normal
liegestützen brauche ich auch in kleinen
ansporn
deswegen hat jeder sieben minuten zeit
in diesen sieben minuten man kann
natürlich auch pause machen kann man so
viele logisch oder soll man so viele die
gestürzt wie möglich machen das heißt
wenn felix nach sieben minuten ach so
zeigt sich mal kurz ok und jetzt wieder
das heißt felix
sieben minuten zum beispiel 300
liegestützen hat ich habe 350 kriege ich
von felix 50 euro weil pro liegestütz
kriegt man vom anderen 1 euro das heißt
sie haben danach eine differenz und ja
das ist so der ansporn dahinter auf
einem kanal macht der felix schütz auf
seinem kanal nach ich liegestütze
das heißt checkt auf jeden fall auf
seinen kanal habt da seht ihr wie ich
liegestütze machen bei uns auch noch
eine kleine weitere challenge überlegt
und zwar wer an diesem tag mehrere nennt
macht also vom anderen kriegt eine fette
bestrafung in einem weiteren video
deswegen tut mir den gefallen geht bei
felix huber aber jetzt einen kanal
heereman ist wirklich korrekter typ und
mal sehen was man dann für dich als
bestrafung finden warum ich eine
bestrafung gut verliert wird die linke
schützen oder nicht nenne ich meine mit
der abonnentenzahl hast du ja das wird
meine community will macht ihr mal keine
sorgen
felix ist ein sehr fähiger im beatles wo
ist der bcs hallo willst du anfang
direkt du mal auf meinem kanal ok freue
ich mich jetzt immer aus komplett nackig
machen bin ich komplett würde woanders
nichts zu suchen
klar freuen ich hab schulter schmerzt
und alex meier ist eine ausrede ich bin
der meinung es ist keine ausrede tut
schon ein bisschen weh alexa gut
vorgelegt einer ausrede
nein alles gut vorgelegt auf meinem
kanal ich bin gespannt was jetzt gemacht
und ist verrate sowas nicht verraten
ich kann gar nicht die kamera halten
ja das ist bei diesen vogel los auf die
wird völlig okay läuft ja ja schon lange
du fängst du was machst du pause also
das ja mal richtig erproben wo bist du
arrogant worin wohin das auf so 1234
was sagt eine heim nach dem ist ein
surfer gefressen hat ne zitiert somit
frühstücksbrettchen geht eine schöne
frauen eine bäckerei und sollte kein
brot darauf der bäcker sachen gibt
johanna zum körper ich wünsche ihm das
geschenk ein pony zu weihnachten papa
geht in ordnung johanna wirklich liebe
dich über alles klappt einfach nicht
abend so johanna den friseurtermin steht
keine ahnung sohn zum vater papa du
sagst mich soll eine kartoffel in die
wade 50 odernähe sagen ich muss es nach
ihm geht eine frau in eine bäckerei und
sagt ich möchte gerne rumkugeln darauf
der bag hat aber nicht in meinem laden
warte mal auf mich schatz ich mache nur
noch schnell mein make up du brauchst
kein make up oder ist aber lieb von dir
ich mag wenn du mich manches junge wie
unwitzig einer ein mann und eine frau
sitzen sollen im restaurant plötzlich
bekleckert was los
habe ich jetzt 70 sony 70 muss nicht
nachzählen machen musik zu machen
also du hast gerade mal obwohl das kann
doch gar nicht sein oder
obwohl doch zwei minuten 18 hast du
jetzt kann das sein kann sein ich weiß
es nicht
ehrlich ich weiß ich habe nicht
mitgezählt ja das bin ich ein
was machst du da so ein bisschen für die
shaolin so ein bisschen bockig
rüberkommen ich weiß ja was vermieden
den kommentaren stehen was ist das würde
für ein arroganter typ hat meine frau
hat mich gebeten ihres lippenbalsam zu
reichen aus versehen gab ich ihr
superkleber sie bricht immer noch nicht
mit mir
wie bringt man einmal was dazu
selbstmord zu begehen
man zeigt auf seine brust und sagt schau
mal du hast da was verstehe ich gar
nicht und muss vom wähler bewusst ich
würde sagen du hast eigentlich jetzt
schon 104 obwohl noch nicht ganz
also ich glaube jetzt noch mal weiter so
einfach kann es noch gar kein witz
lustig ich kann alle bisschen scheiße ja
der vater seinem sohn so und ich muss
dir was sagen so wurde es adoptiert sagt
der sohn was ich würde konnte meine
echten eltern kennen dann darauf ihr
vater wir sind keine echten eltern und
jetzt mach dich fertig du wirst in 20
minuten abgeholt verstehst du denn
hallo ich hab noch gar nicht auf deine
ausführung geachtet
machen wir also muss man korrigieren was
erhält man wenn man einen rottweiler und
ein jaguar kreuzt ärger mit dem
postboten was sind das denn für
schlechte witze der bus auf pump ja
immer
immer na ja also erstmal hier kurz kurz
lang auf die ausführung achten wer das
gut bisschen höher betrieb wenn ihr den
arm richtig durch strecke genauso jawohl
ja jetzt machst du dir auch richtig
hinteren fitnessstudio und dann nicht
mal richtige aussuchen was sind das
jetzt für tricks teaching hofmann das
stretching nach 40 sekunden debatte
stand ob alles gut aber ich warte jetzt
hast du noch und die letzten zehn
sekunden laufen einfach und a1 richtig
auch wenn er richtig
und 4 richtig hoch da also frei und ende
hier stop stop loss verarscht weise habe
ich ganz andere zeit bereit ich hab' ich
habe keine 120 euro bestimmt nicht
meintest du nicht eben als du hier
hängen angekommen ist das zu 100 am
stück schaffte
wir müssen uns jetzt genau zu
analysieren also ich glaube du hast
gewonnen aber nicht du hast gewonnen
deswegen meine ich ernst du hast den
anfang gut vor sich aber er jetzt vor
oft abgeschrieben ich glaub ich auch
also ich glaube du hast bestimmt 30
merzig wir gucken da ich mag gefährlich
warnt also leute wir sehen uns gleich
jetzt läuft also ich muss sagen ich
finde das ja immer cool wenn man seinen
sein video etwas richtig profitabel im
verein also ich hab das wort gemacht und
wir haben video gemacht jetzt ist zwar
meine brust also die ich wirklich will
aber es hat sich auf jeden fall gelohnt
ich habe bei felix gar nicht mitgezählt
deswegen habe ich das jetzt gerade hier
am pc gecheckt und darf jetzt sagen was
ich bei dir geschafft hat also felix hat
auf meinem kanal 126 926 liegestütz
geschafft in sieben minuten aber so
schnell ich muss ich sagen ich hatte
wirklich von dir gedacht okay du machst
du die 180 machst du voll weil ich weiss
nicht am anfang war ich echt ein kleiner
spaß weil ich zu viel gespielt habe und
ich habe beim felix 102 grad geschafft
das heißt wir haben eine differenz von
24 904 einfach 30 euro okay also du
christ jetzt von mir 26 euro ist jetzt
weiß die welt weil sie das tun dann bei
lieber felix 20 25 25 euro von alex
beziehungsweise 26 euro
danke ich dir aleks ganz ganz wichtig
geht alle über abonniert seinen kanal
wir sehen uns vermutlich morgen wieder
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen tag
hat rein vorne